Speaker 1: There is a campaign to be Donald
Trump's vice president going on right now,
and there is really one person who is in that
campaign.
And it is radical, repugnant.
Republican Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE is openly running to
be Trump's VP.
She is trying to dissuade people like Ron
DeSantis.
And when it looked like maybe Carrie Lake
would be the next governor of Arizona, Carrie
Lake from running partially because she wants
to be Trump's VP.
She believes her best shot at being the vice
presidential pick is if Donald Trump is the
nominee.
And we're going to get to that in a moment.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE yesterday was confronted
with a very good question, a very obvious
question.
If Trump is so strong, if Trump is so powerful,
if Trump is so revered in the Republican Party,
why did so many of the people that Donald
Trump endorsed lose and Marjorie Taylor GREENE
Just sort of like with a throw everything
at the wall and see if any of it makes sense.
And so listen to how she answered the question.
Speaker 6: Trump endorsed candidates last
year.
Speaker 7: Including one.
I would say there's I would say it depends
on the district.
I think there's a lot of varying factors.
Redistricting happened and that was based
on the the census that was pretty much pre-COVID.
A lot of people moved out of those districts
over the past few years.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So so.
Oh, my goodness.
So first of all, redistricting only matters
in congressional races.
Trump's biggest losses in the contested races
of consequence, that would have made a difference.
Carrie Lake in Arizona, that's the entire
state.
Redistricting doesn't matter.
Blake Masters in Arizona Senate races or the
entire state redistricting doesn't matter.
Doug Mastriano and Mehmet Oz in Pennsylvania,
Tudor Dickson in Michigan.
These are all statewide races.
Redistricting doesn't matter.
Then Marjorie Taylor GREENE polls well, a
lot of people move during the pandemic to
other states unless you can make the case
that it was disproportionately Republicans
that moved.
That also isn't really a good explanation
for why Trump's endorsements ended up falling
flat.
None of these explanations make sense.
But remember, Marjorie Taylor GREENE is desperate
to be Trump's VP, so she has to come up with
something other than, you know, a lot of people
kind of don't like Trump.
Speaker 7: I think that plays a part.
I think it's a candidate by candidate.
Sometimes one campaign is run really well
and sometimes one is not.
But I would also say the media plays a big
part.
Speaker 1: So then we get to really just blame
the media.
Speaker 7: Media leans pretty hard left.
And so when Republican candidates, when we
run for office, not only are we running against
a Democrat opponent, we're also running against
the media a good bit of the time, and that's
really not fair.
So I think there's a lot of factors at play.
And President Trump's win record is is historic.
Most of his candidates won.
Very few of his candidates lost.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And again, remember, even Republicans are
admitting to the absurdity of that statement,
Trump's record, which he says, oh, we were
like 215 or something, you know, it's every
day it's a different number that he claims.
You mostly endorse incumbents who usually
win or Republicans in safe red races.
That is not impressive.
If I was in the endorsement game, I could
have a really good endorsement record because
there are quite literally hundreds of races
in which it's obvious who's going to win.
Would it really be meaningful?
Would it really be meaningful if I actually
called it in that way?
Because I hate to say it, a couple chimpanzees
could probably call most of the races where
it mattered, where it was contested, where
it could have made a difference in the balance.
Trump failed miserably.
Someone who also failed miserably in.
They endorsements is Tulsi Gabbard.
And after the break, we're going to talk a
little bit about that.